how worried are you
oh i'm i'm not worried
for the world in that i i really do
believe that a lot has been learned
and at the same time the virus is
evolving
but i am worried for individuals
who may be at risk because they are in
the older age group or because they have
other conditions that mean that they are
likely to get severely ill or i'm
worried for people who've decided not to
be vaccinated because i think their
risks are greater as well so it depends
on who you are and i've got my usual
selection of tips that i would love to
offer to people if they are wondering
what they ought to do today whether to
go out whether to wear a mask and so on
and so forth
well tell us do tell us
well thank you
you see the new variants of this virus
they're called ba4 and ba5
of omicron
they seem to be pretty good
at dodging past the protection that some
of us have
from vaccination and so we can get ill
with kovid even though we've been
vaccinated now the illness having just
had it myself four weeks ago
the illness is pretty nasty and it
knocks you out for a week to 10 days if
you're unlucky or for a few days if
you're okay
that illness is for most people
survivable
but it's because a few people are likely
to be at high risk and also because of
the constant worries about long cobaid
that i think people should still keep
their masks in their pockets or in a
little little bag
in the glove compartment of the car
or in their handbag or briefcase just
because if you're going into a place
where there are a lot of people up close
together all the evidence is that that's
where your risks are greatest and in
addition if you start to feel feverish
with a cough
and you're not able to get yourself a
covet test quickly
then again you should wear a mask to
protect other people so that's what i
ask everybody to do is use your mask and
use it when you're feeling ill or use it
when you think you're at risk and do
maintain that physical distancing going
up and giving someone a big hug saying
i've missed you for so long if you're
unlucky that can also be the time when
you give them covid so be careful on the
up close and personal stuff even though
we all want to do it it also carries a
risk in summary
we're getting through this pandemic
we're not through it yet
but we seem to be getting through it
and for many of us now
the illness will be an inconvenience
rather than life-threatening but
remember there are some who are going to
be badly affected and they won't be us
necessarily they might be people that we
just bump into and we accidentally
infect so please let's be re responsible
as well what about the general
population doctor not those who are
necessarily um you know likely to be
incredibly ill if they do succumb to
covid um if you've had the more times
you've had covid i are you building up
immunity against it
sadly not we don't think that the more
times you have it the more immunity you
have because the virus is changing it's
like it's changing its overcoat all the
time and that means it can duck past the
antibodies and other protections that
we've had as a result of previous
infections so i'm not one of those
people who believes that the more times
you get it the more resistant you'll be
i just think that the more times you get
it the more likely you are to be unlucky
and end up with long covered which is
the thing that none of us want because
it can be so serious it can knock people
off their stride for several months
the thing is people don't necessarily
know they've got kovid do they because
we don't test um as a routine anymore
here in the united kingdom
and a lot of people at the moment have
got
hay fever so they don't know if their
symptoms are similar which which they
are um for some people they don't
actually know they've got covered
my son told me that just over the
weekend he said my hope is he was
getting bad dad
and i was just thinking to myself i
still hope you'll do us an auto test as
we call them one of these little tests
that we can all do at home unpleasant
sticking the thing up your nose but you
can get a result within minutes i do
encourage everybody
to have a few auto tests at home and
just in case that's not hay fever but
it's covered it's good to know because
if it is covered you don't want to be
infecting others i know that that it's
difficult having to do the tests on
yourself but that's the way it is and i
do encourage everybody to keep a stock
at home if they possibly can and to use
them when they feel poorly
okay um
actually here at sky we still test each
other twice a week so we're sort of you
know aware of whether we have got
covered um or not just a quick thought
before i go i of course could not let
you go without asking about otto
talking walking beautiful absolutely the
most adorable child
able to zoom with him regularly and i
was able over easter to be with all six
of my astounding grandchildren even
though kovid had messed up our reunions
for the last two years i mean i feel it
like everybody else does isn't it so
good that people are able to get moving
around again they're able to get talking
and and seeing those they love and so
for me the the real challenge over the
next few months is to have the fun to
get life back onto the rails again but
at the same time do everything we can to
avoid just being caught unluckily by
this still quite frustrating virus and
how's their granddad doing after his
bite of covid
oh it's knocked me awfully when i had it
i would get really tired like i was
hitting a wall when i wasn't expecting
it and it's taken me three four weeks to
really get the back of it and i still
have odd days when i feel remarkably
tired that's what it's done for me it's
made me feel super super exhausted with
others it's made them feel uncomfortable
where they've had a bit of discomfort in
a joint or something like that it seems
to be uh capable of of kind of
reigniting it it's a it's a perplexing
virus this i'm sure everybody who's
watching thinks yeah well i've had my
own version of covid and we can't easily
say there's just one pattern of illness
it's very variable